apart from the comment about sitting in
an administrator's office I thought that
was a great great speech and we're very
very just wonderful having Eric and of
course the president as part of our
community and Landy whom I will hear
from for just a second but I think the
thing that is so important is that we
have these young people who join us
every year and they look and see the
people who are ahead of them they see
the integrity the intelligence the
character and the service the attitude
that they bring to to these positions
and there's nothing that you can say
about an institution I think that beyond
what we do for young people and these
role models are just tremendous lanny
breuer your next
Thank You president Bollinger for that
kind introduction it's really a great
honor for me to be here with you all
today and to see so many distinguished
columbia alumni I have so many dear
friends from Columbia who really
remained so much a part of my life both
in DC and throughout the country and for
me it's really an incredible honor to be
here it's remarkable to have so many DC
area Columbia graduates in one place
today and I'm delighted to Kappas as
president Bollinger refer to it to cap
what has really been for me a Columbia
filled week with all of you on Wednesday
coincidentally like the pleasure of
being at Columbia on campus for
discussion with Dean moody Adams in
front of college and university students
and it was really was really terrific
the energy is just extraordinary and
Dean moody Adams could not have been a
more welcoming host and I'm happy to
know that she's our Dean I was really
extremely taken with her strong rapport
that she is clearly built with the
students on campus over a very short
period of time in her tenure and I
believe that she's a tremendous addition
to the University and I encourage all of
you to meet her if you haven't yet on
the video we just all saw Attorney
General Holder praised president
Bollinger zout standing leadership and I
want to emphasize that as well as an
alumnus who has remained connected to
the University I've heard from many
people over the years and I've seen for
myself what a phenomenal advocate for
the university president Bollinger has
been from launching the largest capital
campaign in the university's history to
initiating what may be the most
ambitious expansion of the campus since
president LOH moved the university to
Morningside Heights and eight
97 to raising the overall global profile
of this great university president
Bollinger has shown over the last nine
years the Columbia is so very lucky to
have him at the helm like many of you I
suspect even though I live in DC I'm a
New Yorker at heart i was born in
Manhattan and what was then called
flower Fifth Avenue hospital and I was
raised in Queens just like the Attorney
General did I grew up in elmhurst and he
grew up in East Elmhurst I went to
Newton High School in Elmhurst Queens
and my mother still lives in Queens
today my story is similar to the stories
of many New Yorkers from that time my
parents escaped to the United States
from Europe my mother from Germany and
my father from Austria my mother wasn't
allowed to go to high school at home and
both my parents arrived in New York with
not much more than a desire to have a
better life in a new country that they
hoped would treat them better than the
ones they left they met in Manhattan and
eventually moved to elmhurst where my
brother and I grew up even though
Columbia was just a subway ride away
from us I didn't know much about it as a
high school student I knew that my
smarter second cousin Michael for
Washington Heights had gone there and I
knew the Jewish mothers were happy when
their sons got in or their daughters got
into Barnard but I didn't have a clue
not a clue about the world that Columbia
would eventually open up to me beginning
quite frankly with my very first
assignment in contemporary civilization
reading Plato's Republic I certainly
hadn't ever seen so many smart and
intellectually engaged people together
in
in place columbia college then like new
york in some ways was frankly not always
the easiest place to be socially the
school didn't coddle anyone and
academically it was more rigorous than
anything i had personally known before
but also like New York Columbia moved me
as I imagine it moved you to care about
the world around me and to challenge
myself to reach higher of course not
everyone believes that Columbia is the
pinnacle of higher education Theodore
Roosevelt dropped out of the law school
after one year and he is quoted as
saying a man who has never gone to
school may steal from a freight car but
if he has a university education he may
steal the whole railroad after two years
as head of the Criminal Division where
we prosecute among other things where we
prosecute sophisticated white-collar
crime I can say that I believe TR may
have something there nevertheless for me
after two years two years of teaching
high school abroad I found myself back
in Morningside Heights this time at the
law school and unlike TR I did graduate
although I learned recently that FDR
like his cousin Teddy also went to
Columbia Law School and also left before
graduating given that I wouldn't blame
any law students in the audience for
thinking that you might have a better
shot at becoming president of the United
States if you drop out now and I guess
I'd say that if you're Teddy Roosevelt
or if you're FDR you might be right if
you're anything like the rest of us
though you probably ought to finish
getting your degree with that huge
statue of Bellerophon taming Pegasus
outside the law school it was sometimes
said when i was there at columbia law
school that the law school was the only
horse drawn toaster in the world not
only was it a horse-drawn toaster
because of the architecture but also
because people would say it popped in
idealistic law students and three years
later Wall Street lawyers popped out
maybe there's a kernel of truth to that
but I didn't experience the law school
in that way the school I knew was a
place where commitment to public service
was an exceptionally important value as
the Attorney General just spoke about
before and we're pursuing government
work was strongly encouraged Jerry Lynch
now a judge in the Second Circuit and
the Court of Appeals in New York and
Mark Pomerance who had been the criminal
chief as a federal prosecutor Manhattan
were young professors when I was a law
student and to this day I remember them
and Harold Roth wax a professor of mine
who was an esteemed state court judge
encouraging me in my choice to go to the
Manhattan district attorney's office
over a big firm now I mentioned my
brother how we grew up in Elmer's and I
have to say probably the only good
advice my older brother ever gave me was
when I was debating between the
Manhattan district attorney's office in
a law firm he said to me you know you've
never had any money so you won't know
the difference
but I knew the hard person to convince
was my mother because my mother of
course was that very prototypical
immigrant who had worked hard who had
not been able to go to high school and
who had dreams for her son and among
those dreams of course was to be at a
different economic level than we were so
being the young advocate that I thought
I was I called her up to tell her atma
after after I'd made my decision I was a
third-year law student that I wanted to
go the DA's office so I called her at
home and I said mom I've made a decision
I'm going to go to the Manhattan DA's
office i'm not going to go to a firm and
mom just think about it andrew Cuomo the
son of the governor he's in the
Manhattan DA's office Cyrus Vance the
son of the Secretary of State he's in
the DA's office and mom dan Rather jr.
she loved Dan Rather on CBS he's at the
DA's office there was a long pause and
then I heard the following damned em
they should go to the DA's office you
you should go to a firm
well I eventually won her over I
eventually would also at some point go
to a firm so it all worked in any event
after four years in the district
attorney's office and a lifetime in New
York I made my way like all of you to
Washington DC some people say that
Washington is a city of southern
efficiency and northern charm but maybe
because I'm from Queens I actually think
this city brims with charming is full of
nice people either way whichever way you
come out on that one in preparing for
today I was surprised to learn that
there are 10,000 columbia alumni in the
DC area but as I reflected on the
reasons why I came to Washington and the
reasons i bet why so many columbia
graduates i know eventually settled here
it doesn't surprise me much at all there
is a deep tradition of public service at
columbia that runs back all the way to
the Revolutionary era columbia was
founded and developed by american
patriots like John J the first Chief
Justice of the United States and
Alexander Hamilton the first secretary
of the Treasury Charles Evan use and
Harlan Fisk stone successful successive
chief justices of the Supreme Court went
to Columbia Law School and they actually
graduated as at benjamin cardozo and
Ruth Bader Ginsburg dwight d eisenhower
of course served as president of
Columbia from 1948 until the time he
became president of the United States in
1953 and of course our current president
president barack obama his class of
nineteen eighty-three from the college
an attorney general holder as you know
graduated from both the college and the
law school in the 70s in short public
service
the highest levels of government is as
much a part of the culture of columbia
as groundbreaking medical research or
Nobel prize-winning economic theory I
want to take this moment to say a word
about the Attorney General whom I know
you all were regionally expecting to
hear from today in person he is a great
patriot and a tremendous lawyer who as
president Bollinger said has devoted his
career to public service as a prosecutor
a judge the US Attorney for the District
of Columbia the Deputy Attorney General
of the United States and now as our
nation's 82nd Attorney General he is
also a real and dear friend and
colleague and it is a true honor for me
to serve in the Justice Department under
his leadership he has succeeded in my
view and restoring the department to its
rightful place in American society
something about which I think all
Americans can and should be very proud
and I personally have had no greater
professional honor in my life than to
lead the criminal division these past
two years fighting the diverse threats
we face requires vigilance and
creativity from widespread financial
fraud to child pornography to Mexican
drug cartel related violence to
organized crime to foreign bribery and
other forms of corruption we are up
against very sophisticated foes and the
divisions nearly 600 lawyers together
with US Attorneys offices around the
country are working hard to investigate
and prosecute the full range of federal
crimes starting with Attorney General
Holder the message to these prosecutors
is clear our number-one mission number
one is to see the justices to
not that we win cases or make headlines
but that we live up to the ideal of
Attorney General and later Supreme Court
Justice Robert Jackson we told a group
of federal prosecutors in 1940 he said a
sensitiveness to fair play and
sportsmanship is perhaps the best
protection against the prosecutors abuse
of power and the citizens safety lies in
the prosecutor who temper zeal with
human kindness who seeks truth and not
victims who serves the law and not
factional purposes and who approaches
his task with humility these are
incredibly important values for any
prosecutor and I'd like to think that
all of our lawyers are striving to
uphold them at Columbia among so many
brilliant and accomplished people one
learns to approach lots of tasks with
humility it's an institution that
attracts people from all over the world
because among other things big ideas are
generated there in dozens and dozens of
fields it has a bold leader and
president Bollinger who is cultivating
what's best about the University while
pursuing it toward new heights coming
from where I did Columbia meant the
world to me and it still does it has
been an honor to share this day with you
thank you and have a great afternoon
thank you so much Lenny and I really
mean it when I say that the sort of tone
and the substance are all unified in
making one very very proud about this
leadership of what has to be a core of
American society and that is justice and
the rule of law and but also the sense
of connection to Columbia that you
express and have maintained in your
heart is really very meaningful to
everyone here Lana has agreed to take a
few questions so that's great for us and
if anybody wants to ask a question
please go to the microphone so once in a
lifetime opportunity so I wouldn't go
that far so my name is Eddie I chest I
was going to ask you about the
government shutdown and how will it
affect justice and I will affect others
and more more as to that rather than the
potential for settlement because
obviously we don't know whether that
will happen well I mean we're all very
very hopeful that there will not be a
government shutdown we're committed to
continuing to support the people of the
United States and our prosecutors will
be in court we will continue to do the
business of the court but obviously it's
a tremendous challenge and we've all had
to think through what would happen if
that eventualities Kurt I'm very hopeful
that'll be averted I don't think that
that would serve the American people
either miss Brewer thank you for
speaking with today my name is Richard
I'm a student in college leave to serve
as an intern in the White House so great
I just wanted to and I guess a lot of
the stuff we do there is a hold of any
young leadership kind of cultivating on
people to take on leadership roles what
would your greatest advice be too young
to these students at the college
or you know undergraduates in general to
know pursuit leadership opportunities in
public service and really contribute to
society through the opportunities at
Columbia well what I said the other day
and I guess my view in life and what I
say to my own kids and really what I've
tried to do for myself is I've always
tried to pursue what I thought would be
fun I think it's really hard to do well
at anything if you don't get personal
satisfaction and enjoyment in it so my
recommendation and if you're interning
at the White House you'll see that the
one unifying view in my my perspective
it certainly was what I took out of the
Clinton White House when I was fortunate
enough to work there was you had people
from diverse backgrounds diverse
interest of our skill sets but the one
common theme was they loved and had a
passion for what they did and I think if
you have a love and a passion for what
you do then you can become and will
become a leader because you'll just said
it won't be artificial it will generate
a level of excitement you want to do
more and so I know in this day and age
people are always trying to figure out
what with the economy and with other
areas what's what's the best way to go
and maybe I'm wrong but the advice I
would give since you asked me is pursue
what's in your heart and then you'll do
well that's what I would do Gregory
krasovsky Columbia College 91 on a
personal level I think I made a big
mistake by choosing Penn law school as
opposed to Columbia but they won me over
with a scholarship as the head of the
Criminal Division of the US Department
of Justice one of the things you face
today is a very serious in unix
situation where we have to deal with
threats of terrorism and other things
that threaten the security of our
country but at the same time we know
that our country as president Bulger's
properly pointed out was founded on
principles of justice and liberty I
think it was Benjamin Franklin found
mistaken and said people who are willing
to sacrifice their liberties for
security will have neither how do you
make that fine balance especially in
process
ocean of national security in tears
related cases and how do you make those
choices as a columbia law in a columbia
college graduate as a lawyer I've had
experience of living and working in the
former Soviet Union and Russia and I've
seen how prosecution of various cases
can really curtail people's liberties
and it would certainly hate to see the
u.s. go the same way even to a tiny
extent so let me begin by saying in all
seriousness I'm the assistant attorney
general for the criminal division and
indeed since 911 and the Patriot Act
there is now a division the national
security division and its focus is on
terrorism and so day to day others an
assistant attorney general whose
remarkable who focuses on that look as
the Attorney General himself has said
and has said repeatedly the nation's
security is the paramount and the number
one priority for this administration and
for this department of justice we will
remain adamant and vigilant in doing
that there are different ways that that
can be accomplished sometimes we will do
it suit civil courts some time if
Congress and others tell us we will do
it through other means whether it's
through military tribunals and the like
I think there are different ways to
solve the nation's problems and to
address the concerns and I think the
debate that's had is the debate that's
sincerely held by well-meaning people I
don't think there's just one answer what
I think there is though is an absolute
commitment by this department in this
administration to hold those who would
do harm to the United States accountable
we remain vigilant the Attorney General
stays up morning noon and night and
others of us do to support him and so we
will continue to do it and in a moment
of personal privilege I see my friend
for 35 years and he was on my dorm
Carmen Hall first year right behind you
David Lee hi David good afternoon my
name is Philip Dolan I'm a graduate of
the college and the school
arts I want to ask a question it
concerns me that we have such a large
prison population in the United States
right I think it's three million or
something like that and I'm a lot of it
as drug offenses and I'm wondering to
comment on shore absolutely well I think
it's a little over two million in the
federal population is about 225 for
230,000 look you're absolutely right
it's a real issue this Attorney General
has said and this administration has
said that we look and are very committed
to a comprehensive approach to dealing
with these kinds of issues there's
absolutely no question that there is a
group of people who must be incarcerated
will be incarcerated and we will
continue to seek severe punishments for
them but there's also absolutely no
question that we have to have retraining
programs rehabilitation programs and
manners of alternate sentencing for big
groups of people on the big believer in
that I was recently at a federal
penitentiary and and it's really quite
remarkable the skills that some of these
Penitentiary's are able to teach the
inmates and frankly it's remarkable how
dedicated and idealistic the people who
work in the prisons are and i really
think sometimes those people are not
given the credit that they are due
there's no question that's got to be a
part of it we can't continue to be
incarcerated you know the kinds of
numbers we are and it's just going to
have to be a balance it's a
comprehensive approach it's a
comprehensive approach that deals with
the education of our children it's a
comprehensive approach about what our
communities want to do with our children
and it's a comprehensive approach with
what we're going to do once we
incarcerate them there's no easy answers
but the Attorney General is a true
leader in this area we're focusing a lot
on it and will continue to do so
planning on behalf of all of us thank
you so much for being here with us Thank
You president Bollinger Thank You lanny
breuer i love the story about your
mother I know she's proud and also the
words from Supreme Court Justice Robert
Jackson I what president Bollinger said
something about pride and that's exactly
what I was sitting there thinking as I
listened to Attorney General Holder and
to assistant attorney general Brewer
that how proud we all are of all of
these people who are doing such
important work for our government for
our country so thank you very much
worship we're fortunate today to have so
many leaders in the government who are
who are here with us who will be at
lunch many of you who are leaders in
many ways and doing outstanding things I
know there's going to be some great
networking going on at lunch we will all
go out to the atrium staff will direct
you to your tables you're sitting at
assigned tables for the most part based
on the school from which you graduated
so if you will proceed to lunch we will
be back here starting promptly at two
o'clock so i'll see you at 158 I know
you didn't pay attention to me the last
time but i'll see you at 158 thank you